yes hi I'm Johanna and I've just
launched a platform for connecting
companies with social media influencers
okay like a tinder self-direct and i
thought i had kind of a unicorn and now
when kind of exploring the world i say
okay there's a lot out there so how
about is doing but we're kind of late
here in this part of the world yep so
here I captured the markets really well
in a short time that's awesome but I
wonder how my dreams about
internationalization and getting global
and making it scalable making it bigger
what advice would you give to me for
that well a couple things first of all
how big is it in the market that you're
winning in it the biggest thing that you
know that like unless you're doing seven
1012 million dollars in the Nordics you
should not be thinking about Eastern
Western Europe us too many people like
every word out of your mouth is the [ __ ]
that I was just talking Excalibur what
like we're just all caught up in
building billion-dollar it's so stupid
like how big is your company how much
are you doing over a million we have a
pretty revenue but he loves I mean he
just launched it until you [ __ ] make
money you shouldn't be worried about
global know so many local markets go
that way vaynermedia than seventy five
million dollars in revenue profitably
before I thought about even going to
London okay everybody's caught listen
I'm telling you all of you you're caught
up in [ __ ] propaganda you're not
thinking about it smartly you make no
money and you're sitting here worried
about winning globally and you haven't
even started winning locally you
understand yeah I'm just thinking like
this partnership the way to go to
somebody that are all know the way to go
is to not think about it at all okay do
you understand yeah yeah like the way to
think about it is well no I mean ninety
nine percent likely it won't happen but
if you're one percent that's good enough
to actually execute and get to the place
where you go global then you get to go
global
but nobody is global right away but
everybody looks at Facebook and uber
like uber started in just San Francisco
uber so guys we're spending a year and a
half just trying to figure out San
Francisco
a year and a half the understand yeah no
it's not it's a long time in the way
that you're wired right now yeah a year
and a half is nothing
[Music]